STEPHEN CARPENTER: I thought
these three questions could be
part of our conversation later.
I want us to get up and
actually create a public work.
But I've been thinking
about how might
contemporary art
and social practice
enable conversations
about difficult subjects?
And that's part of what
we're interested in.
Couldn't that be the
focus of a curriculum?
A multi-week, a
multi-session unit
of instruction with
learners of a range of ages
and in the range of spaces.
Or why prepare
teachers as agents
of positive social change?
I mean, some people say, oh, we
have to prepare them for that,
but why?
What would come out of that?
Or why not, right?
What does it mean?
Maybe the question
should be what
does it mean for
teachers to be prepared
as agents for social change?
Some of you are studying in
departments or programs, where
social change, social activism,
positive social responsibility
is central to the mission.
Why do that?
Is that such a good thing?
Or how can creative
responses to social injustice
interrupt conditions
of inequality?
We might not be
able to change them.
Might not be able to stop them.
But maybe it interrupts
it just long enough
to reposition or find
other ways, other tactics,
other approaches to engage.
I think this is a
good time to stop.
And let's get up, and let's
make some public trouble.
I brought with me
some children's books.
And I also brought
some children's toys.
How many of you
brought cellphones?
How many of those
cellphones take pictures?
Oh, yeah.
Now we can work as individuals.
We can work in pairs
or trios, if we want.
All right?
I have some
children's books here.
I'll share them--
show these to you.
Not all of them deal with
uncomfortable stories.
Some of them do.
There's a whole range of
things, like Flat Stanley.
I don't know if you know
of the Flat Stanley.
To me, there's a Henry
Box Brown deal here,
where you can mail individuals
to different places.
Here, he's pretty happy about
going to visit his family.
But Henry couldn't do that.
Or The Big Orange Splot,
this is about one house
being different.
And then I won't ruin the
story for you at the end,
but it's about
finding your own way.
Little Blue and
Little Yellow, I don't
know if you know this story.
But when you mix blue and
yellow, you get green.
And what does it mean
to be blue or yellow?
And how does mixing happen?
Tar Beach, about a
little girl who--
she doesn't have something
or can't go somewhere.
She just imagines that
she can fly there,
and she can capture
that experience.
Bell Hooks-- I don't know if you
know her children's book, Skin
Again.
There's a wonderful book about
learning disabilities, reading,
in particular.
And it's called The
Art of Miss Chew, where
the art teacher,
her art teacher,
essentially figured out she was
seeing the world differently.
Her reading-- and
she was reading
the spaces between the words,
not the words themselves.
Just like an artist might try
to render the negative space,
rather than the positive space.
Or a Maya Angelou poem and a
Jean-Michel Basquiat poem put
together--
or Jean-Michel Basquiat images
and a Maya Angelou poem, Life
Doesn't Frighten Me Anymore.
These are children's books
that I found kids respond to
in interesting ways.
So you might choose
one of these books
and find one of those
unexpected public spaces,
where you don't think education
or art, making your art
practice, is supposed to happen.
You could take one
of these books,
and go and read
it there out loud.
And have somebody else or
yourself video tape you or--
not video tape, you
can tell how old I am.
What is it?
Make a video, a
mobile video of you.
And you can put one
of the hashtags.
Where are our hashtags, Steve?
Here it is.
You can hashtag it, and
pop it up on social media,
if you'd like.
Or you can take still
photo of yourself
or someone else
reading out loud.
Or you can take several.
Document that experience.
What would be interesting
is to see what kind
of social interaction happens.
And think about the critique.
Remember those little
tiny townspeople
and the tiny presidents?
The critiques of
then the stories
of the little people and
the stories of those spaces.
There's a conversation
that happens.
Think about the story you
might read in that space
in relationship to that space.
Or I have these little toys,
just three firefighters,
two of whom have razor stub
and one has a mustache.
I wonder how gendered this is.
I'm just asking
questions right now.
Or little animals.
Or I have little
Lego mini figures.
These have to be put together.
I mean, you're welcome to take
them, and put them together,
and use them in the ways that
you saw in the photographs,
critiquing, having a
conversation in a public space.
That story-- where's
my-- oh, there it is,
Henry's Freedom Box.
I think I'm going to take
one of these pallets.
I can't take both of them.
I'm going to take one of
these, and I'm going outside.
I'm going to read
this book outside.
I'm going to perform
that story outside.
Henry was lonely.
One day, he met Nancy, who
was shopping for her mistress.
They walked, and talked,
and agreed to meet again.
Henry felt like singing.
But slaves didn't dare
sing in the streets.
Instead, he hummed
all the way home.
Henry knew they were very lucky.
They lived together, even though
they had different masters.
STUDENT 1: "Life doesn't
frighten me at all, not at all.
Life doesn't
frighten me at all."
Thanks a lot.
GIRL: Well, what's this for?
STUDENT 1: Oh, it's a class
assignment I'm having.
GIRL: Oh, OK.
I noticed there are some
other people as well.
STUDENT 1: There are
a couple other people
doing the same thing.
GIRL: [LAUGHS]
STUDENT 2: "The house was
looking like it was green."
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Does anyone want
to talk about-- you want to
talk about your own specific
experience, either reading
a book out loud in public
or reading a public space in
conversation with your figure?
STUDENT 2: Mainly,
people ignored me.
Some people, like you
said, made sort of a wide--
somebody came, realized
they were sort of
in the scope of the photograph.
And oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh.
And you were taking
a photograph,
and you said, no, no, it's OK.
You can go in.
No, no, no, I'm good.
So that was interesting.
I used to love to read
children's books to my kids.
So I mean, it was
just so much fun
to be out there and
showing everybody.
And some people looked
at me, like oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
And some people smiled.
And I saw people sort of taking
pictures as they walked by.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: They looked
stealth at the time, right?
STUDENT 2: [LAUGHS] Exactly.
And then I was
watching you, and I
saw somebody doing posing off
to the side in front of you,
like wanting to have a picture.
They figured this
was some thing.
And they wanted to be in
it, but not really in it.
So they were off on the
side, posing while you--
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT 3: That
fascinates me, though.
If you don't even
know what it is,
why are you so desperate
to get a picture?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Nicholas
Mirzoeff, visual culture
scholar, uses the
word "sublime" to talk
about those visual moments,
or those moments that are so
repulsive, you can't look away.
And so seductive, you
can't bear to look at it.
I mean, it's that tension.
But he calls that the sublime.
So maybe there is something
sublime about that
that they wanted to
be part, but not.
They knew something
was going on,
but they weren't supposed
to be part of it.
STUDENT 4: I don't know
if we were doing it right.
But I just had a
little Lego guy, and--
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Can we
see the little Lego guy?
STUDENT 4: Yes.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Can you describe--
STUDENT 4: And we
were just playing--
he is a ninja with a hatchet.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Of course.
STUDENT 4: And so we
playing around with
whether he had the hatchet
or not had the hatchet
and giving him--
he had different pictures from
magazines or the newspaper.
And he was in
different contexts.
And I put him on
the water bubbler
and was playing with him
on the water bubbler.
But it was
interesting, and I did
think that my kids
would have a lot of fun.
My students would have
a lot of fun with it.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
So, the hatchet--
tell me about why with
and without the hatchet?
Is this the accessorizing,
or why was--
STUDENT 4: We had him in
front of the headlines.
And according to the headline,
if he had the hatchet,
the headline meant one thing.
But if he didn't, then it
meant a different thing.
So that context changed, once
that weapon was introduced.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK, can
you give us an example of one
of those headlines?
STUDENT 4: Someone
won an reward.
And we put him in front of that.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
With the hatchet?
STUDENT 4: With the hatchet,
which made it a little bit more
ominous.
And then without the
hatchet, he was like, yay,
I got this award.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: [LAUGHS]
So you see in that example,
you're playing with the
various symbolic meanings that
are referenced with
not just the ninja,
but with that
hatchet and the text.
So there's the layered readings.
And even that subtle
seemingly innocuous change
of hatchet or not
hatchet shifts readings--
shifts meaning there.
It's very powerful.
I hope some of what
we've talked about
gives you beginning
points or places
of departure for your own
work as educators or artists.
Continue this work.
See what else you can trouble,
what other kinds of questions
you can ask, what other
stories might be told.
Maybe take the little figures,
and go make some more imagery.
Maybe find a fire hose, or
attempt other performances.
Maybe this is an assignment that
would work with your students,
and give it a shot.
And if it does or if it
doesn't, maybe share it.
Social media, drop me a line.
We'd love to hear what you're
up to as a ripple from what
we're doing here.
I said yesterday, and last week,
as an artist, as an educator,
as a researcher, I
have found that I'm
more interested in
questioning the answers
than I am in answering
the questions.
And for me, the answers are
those social constructs,
those practices, those systems
that people have put in place.
Sometimes remaining
unquestioned or under analyzed.
And maybe art making
through social engagement
is one way to
provoke reflection,
hoping to discover
something in the process
about those constructs.
I'll leave you with this.
The National Art
Education Association
is a professional
organization in North America.
It's open internationally.
Primarily made of
K-12 art teachers,
but there are
other art educators
in the group, higher education
professionals, museum
educators.
There are two
journals they publish.
Studies in Art Education,
which is essentially
the Journal of Issues and
Research in art education.
And then Art Education, which
is essentially primarily
for K-12 and museum educators.
And each issue,
they typically have
six articles in here and
then an instruction resource.
But this particular
special issue
that came out in July of
2017 is a special issue.
And the call for the theme
was creative activity
as a human right.
And the editor said,
instead of getting six,
I want to see how
many I can get.
So he cut down the length
of the submissions.
These are shorter pieces,
but they're really
potent little pieces.
There are so many in here.
One of the articles in here is
called "Socially Engaged Art
Education--
Practices, Processes,
and Possibilities."
And it's about ceramic water
filters, public performance,
socially engaged art.
And I co-authored this
with two colleagues,
Ross Schlemmer, who is a
professor of art education
in southern Connecticut,
and Erika Hitchcock,
who is a high school art
teacher in Virginia Beach.
And so the three of us
put our voices together
to talk about our
experiences here.
The other piece that I
wanted to share with you
is one that was written
by three art educators
at Maryland Institute
College of Art in Baltimore.
I just want to read
the opening paragraph
to you and then another
excerpt, and then we
can have a final
set of comments.
Their article is called
"Baltimore Uprising--
Empowering Pedagogy for Change."
And it was written by Vanessa
López, Adriane Pereira,
and Shyla Rao.
"The Baltimore uprising
was in response
to the death of Freddie
Gray, who was fatally
injured in April 2015 while
in police custody in Baltimore
City.
The first evening
of the uprising,
we were home, glued
to the television,
communicating with each other
and our pre-service teachers,
worried about violent
protests that were
erupting in parts of the city."
That's one of those moments
within your own community
that changes the community.
Certainly now, Freddie
Gray's name is well-known.
And so these three art
education professors,
who were working with
pre-service teachers,
were faced with this
real life situation.
And what is our responsibility,
as art educators, as artists,
as teachers, as citizens
within this community,
to prepare our teachers to face
these issues, these situations?
And how do we do so responsibly?
Not only as community
members and related to them,
to these teachers
as our students,
but knowing that these
folks are going to become
teachers who might face
similar situations.
And they constructed a pedagogy.
They called it a pedagogy
for change framework.
I just want to read briefly what
they wrote and then open it up.
Because I think this piece
goes to the heart of what
this theme for
this week has been,
dealing with
difficult situations
and challenging
social constructs,
primarily in this
case, police brutality.
There's elements of white
supremacy and racism
that flow throughout as well.
They said, "If we, alongside
our pre-service teachers
engage with self."
That's the first piece.
So there's four
components here, self.
"To understand the
intersections of identities
from our lived
experiences, examined
through the lens of
the historical context
of established social injustices
in schools and communities."
Context being the second.
"Then we have an
informed understanding
of these complexities
that," three,
"students contribute
to the cultural assets
of every classroom,
with the goal
of developing a critical for
pedagogy for effecting change
were deemed necessary."
So the culmination of self--
not only teachers, but also
the selves of the students--
in understanding the context--
social, cultural,
political, locational--
and bringing the students
in there as cultural assets
within the conversation.
Perhaps the pedagogy
emerges from that formula.
I think it's a brilliant piece.
And they walk through each
of those components for you.